they make it their business to mind your
business the ban on lace panties in
Kazakhstan Russia and Belarus has
sparked protests in Columbia South
Carolina now requires a license fee and
15-day advance notice to feed the
homeless in city parks the regulations
kick in for groups of 25 or more Food
Not Bombs an organization with a
shoestring budget fears how the added
expense of at least 120 bucks per week
will hurt its mission of feeding the
homeless but this month we zero in on
California that learned to code boot
camps students spend about 10 weeks and
around 15 grand on programs that often
lead to good-paying tech jobs and that's
something the state of California
refuses to tolerate it never mind that
the Golden State's unemployment rate is
the nation's fifth highest the real
problem is that boot camps don't have
state licenses so says the California
Bureau for private post-secondary
education which recently doled out a
bunch of cease and desist letters many
boot camps say they didn't know about
the licensing requirements in fear they
might go bankrupt before the licensing
process which can take up to 18 months
runs its course
not to worry says Russ high Merrik of
the BPPV
as long as they are making a good effort
to come into compliance with the law
they fall down low on our triage of
problem children well maybe the problem
children should follow the university
model jack up tuition n failed to
prepare students for the job market then
California might stop busting coding
boot camps and start subsidizing them
instead follow Nana the month on Twitter
submit your nanny nominees and check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your business